es el primer soldado ruso en ser juzgado
por cometer un crimen de guerra padín sí
sí marín de 21 años está acusado de
asesinar a un civil ucraniano desarmado
mientras montaba en bicicleta según los
fiscales el sargento ruso disparó al
hombre de 62 años en la cabeza a través
de la ventanilla abierta del vehículo el
incidente tuvo lugar en el pueblo en oro
oriental de chiba kicks acá en la región
de summit justo después del inicio de la
guerra el abogado de sisi marín dijo que
el caso contra su cliente es fuerte y
que aún no había decidido como se
declarará windsurf se entregó por su
cuenta todas las demás cuestiones están
relacionadas con el procedimiento
material y penal todo esto serán
audiencias posteriores él dará todas las
respuestas a todas estas cuestiones
cuando declara o no
si es condenado se enfrenta a una pena
de hasta cadena perpetua el caso es
extremadamente importante para kiev ya
que las autoridades presionan para que
rusia rinda cuentas por lo que describen
como atrocidades inimaginables llevadas
a cabo por las fuerzas rusas los
fiscales dicen que están investigando
más de 10.000 posibles crímenes de
guerra que implican a más de 600
sospechosos
el kremlin continúa negando haber
atacado a civiles y acusa a kiev de
organizar ataques como parte de los
esfuerzos para desprestigiar a las
tropas rusas